Israel's government changed its mind
overnight and will allow a visit from
one of the two Democratic Congress women
it had barred from entering the country
rashida to lead will get a humanitarian
pass to visit relatives in the West Bank
but her colleague Ilhan Omar is still
excluded the Israel's Prime Minister
moved to keep them out yesterday after
pressure from President Trump senior
foreign affairs correspondent and Face
the Nation moderator Margaret Brennan
joins us Margaret a huge contingent from
Congress just went to Israel for a visit
how did these two get excluded well it's
this part of the argument really
politically with the so called squad in
this case no American Congress person
had ever been barred from Israel but
this was an extraordinary act president
Trump got them to block two of his
political opponents and it turned this
feud into a diplomatic incident I think
would be a terrible thing
frankly for Israel to let these two
people who speak so badly about Israel
President Trump said allowing the first
two Muslim Congress women into Israel
would show great weakness claiming they
hate Israel and all Jewish people could
the macaca persistent Israeli Prime
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu a friend of
the President
swiftly banned them Dan Shapiro was US
ambassador to Israel under President
Obama could this backfire for Israel
it's a very damaging thing and I think
it unfortunately is exactly what
President Trump wants he has said is the
Democrats are an anti-israel party and
anti-semitic parties these are absurd
slurs but he's trying to get those ideas
cemented into the into the public
discourse Democrats protested the
decision as did Republican senators
Marco Rubio and Susan Collins even the
powerful pro-israel lobby AIPAC said the
Congress women should be allowed to
visit Omar has been critical of AIPAC
and was widely accused of anti-semitism
for saying the committee funded
Republican support for Israel
Talib said blacklisting her was a sign
of weakness and posted a picture of her
Palestinian grandmother who she would
have been prevented from visiting Omar
said it undermined democratic values and
accused mr. Trump of being an
Islamophobe the
to have been vocal critics of both mr.
Trump and Netanyahu and support a
boycott of Israel over its treatment of
Palestinians the lawmakers have faced
past accusations of anti-semitism claims
they denied in an interview with Gayle
King in July would you like people to
would you like to make it clear that you
were not anti-semitic Oh certainly not
yes would you like to make that clear
yes I mean and that nothing I said at
least to me was meant for that purpose
well now Democratic leaders have united
behind the two controversial freshmen
Congress women who the president has
tried to make the face of the Democratic
Party and being in lockstep with
President Trump may also benefit
Netanyahu he's just three weeks out from
a very tight election Anthony Marco what
was the purpose of their trip and what
exactly did Israel fear about the visit
well the to Congress women say that they
plan to go on a humanitarian visit of
the West Bank to see the living
conditions of Palestinians they've been
harshly critical of Israel's treatment
of them and looking at the itinerary it
was a group of visits with UN officials
and others and it was planned by
Palestinian peace maker but now that
that trip is off the itinerary is
cancelled and talib says she's just
going to visit her 9 year old
grandmother all right Margaret thank you